so this is a dungeon which is the kind
of place where people might hire to film
porn accessing Misha Mayfair's porn
films is about to become more difficult
the masks are at orbit not intimidating
and like a lever kind of straightjacket
under the government's porn block you'll
soon have to prove your age to look at a
UK porn website it was a much heralded
policy to protect children but plans
have been delayed once again amid
serious concerns over personal data
being collected when they consulted
about the shape of age verification last
summer they were surprised to find that
nearly everybody who wrote back to them
in that consultation said that this was
a privacy disaster and they need to make
sure that people's data doesn't get
leaked out because it could be that
people are outed that they have their
relationships break down if you don't
want to enter your data online you'll
also be able to pop into your local
corner shop not to buy anything off the
top shelf but if you show your ID you'll
be able to buy a 5-pound bouncer from
behind the counter to put into a website
instead you simply scan the the request
to prove your age it'll check the device
and you're done
that's it the government has left it up
to the porn industry to decide how
they'll verify users ages the company
behind the so called porn passes believe
they have the solution to concerns over
privacy our premises in order to do
something all you need to do is prove
what you are not who you are it's super
safe because we have zero data the only
way to be safe is if you don't record
any data we have got literal stalks here
which are interesting another loophole
means social media isn't included in the
law and Misha who uses Twitter to
promote her work believes the plans are
deeply flawed in general you can't trust
the state and companies to babysit your
children I think what it comes down to
is you really have to monitor what your
kids are doing online and how much free
access they have to the internet because
all of the internet you know Facebook
YouTube can contain things that you
don't want your child to see slowly
that's completely unrealistic parents
cannot watch everything that their child
even when the companies and the
government have come together to try and
stop you have filtered the content that
children are seeing it hasn't worked the
government say this work is a
world-leading step forward to protect
children industry campaigners say the
delays reinforced just how difficult the
law will be to implement Lucy Cotter
Sky News